FREE, NINE AND 11 IN RED, ITFIR
INTERMISSION.
BY NOSEK.
TH THAT
THHE DID.AY,
THE BRUINS GET THE
THEIR COACHING STAFF HAVE
PREPARED
HE IS CHECKED BY COYLE.
GREAT EFFOFOTHIS PLAY.
THE PANTHERS ARE TRYING TO MAKE
A
TAYLORORIT TIGHT.
>> THE SECOND
ODD MAN RUSH THE PANTHERS HAVE
HAD.
RE
SEASON.
ANOTHER BEAUTIFUL PLAY BY SAM
RERE
ONCE AGAIN, I DON'T TONIGHT
WITH THE PANTHERS.
NOT  HUSTLES DOWN FOR NOT
QUICK ENOUGH.
SHOTS IN THE
FIRST PERIOD.
THEY HAVE FOUR ALREADY, HERE IN
THE SE HUBERDEAUB  PUT A 2-1
BREAK WITH, THEY
STEVE AT GOOGLE FOR ON FOR NOW.
GOAL
OVER TO SAM REINHART, HE WILL
HAND IT TO
>> Steve: THE 6-0 PANTHERS HAVE
COMEME
WELL, WILL DUMP IN.HEAD, GOT IN
TRAVERTINE, TURNED BACK TO
CENTER.
Steve:E LIKE.
NO
TRAVERTINE COME IN BEHIND THE
NET.
NOW, THE PANTHERS DOES POSSESS
IT INSteve: HERE COMES TO THE N.
PUT THE
SAM BENNETT, SLIPS
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
CLEARED THE ZONE AND HAD AMPLE
TIME TO MAKE
AND OTHERS STOP BY TRENTON, GOT
PASTRNAK, McAVOY, AGAIN. TO STA
SEASON 7-PLAYERS ARE TIRED.
THEIR TOP LINE FOR
THEY ALL COUNT.
ONE